[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans les
débris du doc dans ce numéro nous allons
nous intéresser aux documentaires
chasseur d'aurores consacré aux
passionnés d'aurores boréales on les
appelle aussi aux aurores polaires ce
sont des phénomènes lumineux vert bleu
ou encore jaune qui apparaissent dans le
ciel ceux qui les observent ces
chercheurs de rohr sont capables de
parcourir des centaines de kilomètres
parfois dans des conditions extrêmes
pour ne pas les louper et pour en parler
avec nous jolin sten astronomes et
planétologues français bonjour jean
lui-même steyn merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france merci beaucoup au gym vous
avez regardé ce documentaire qu'en
avez-vous pensé
à moi je trouve formidable que des gens
se passionnent pour les aurores polaires
et des astronomes amateurs j'ai beaucoup
de relations avec les astronomes
amateurs et je trouve toujours fructueux
et enrichissant d'avoir des échanges
avec eux donc bravo super avant d'aller
plus loin jean lille un stand est ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer ce qu'est une
aurore boréale
d'accord il faut comprendre que tout
part du soleil le soleil c'est une
étoile et comme toutes les étoiles il
envoie en l'espace de la lumière on a
l'habitude de ça bien sûr mais aussi on
en a moins l'habitude de l'électricité
on appelle ça le vent solaire et ce vent
solaire se propage dans tout le système
solaire et earth est évidemment la terre
la terre c'est une planète qui est un
champ magnétique et ce champ magnétique
c'est aussi quelque chose qui revient
avec l'électricité si bien que vent
solaire est sensible aux champs
magnétiques de la terre alors il
commence par faire tout un parcours un
petit peu compliqué autour de la terre
et tourne autour de la terre il se passe
beaucoup de choses mais tout ou tard il
est happé par le pôle nord ou le pôle
sud magnétique elle se dirige ce vent
solaire cette électricité vers le pôle
nord ou toxiques mais évidemment une
poule noire une pole sites sont dans la
terre ils sont pas à l'extérieur ils
sont dans la terre les maux de la terre
est à l'intérieur de la terre si bien
que ces particules en essayant de
rejoindre la terre vont heurter
l'atmosphère au-dessus
de 80 km d'altitude et ça se produit sur
un cercle autour du pôle nord magnétique
parce qu'évidemment elle voudrait toutes
convergé comme dans un entonnoir un vers
le pôle nord mais peuvent pas
l'atmosphère qui les en empêche en cours
de route au dessus de 80 kilomètres
d'altitude elle heurte l'atmosphère
l'atmosphère se met à vibrer alors ça
peut être des diverses excitation assez
des molécules l'atmosphère et c'est
comme ce que vous respirez un des
molécules d'azoté d'oxygène l'azoté
l'oxygène peut se mettre à tourner sur
lui même à cause d'une collision à
vibrer et tout un la vibration s'arrête
la rotation s'arrête et l'énergie qui
avaient été donnés dans la collision est
rendue sous forme de lumière ça
s'appelle une aurore boréale alors dans
ce documentaire on suit natalia kills
chasse aux oies d'aurore à saint
pétersbourg elle nous raconte comment sa
passion pour les aurores boréales aînés
regardez
les aurores boréales sont la passion de
natalia c'est à saint pétersbourg il ya
six ans qu'elle en a vu pour la première
fois depuis elle voyage à travers le
pays pour en voir d'autres magazines
nous étions sortie faire des courses
pour nous avons vu une énorme couronne
d'aurores boréales juste au dessus de
nous
c'était un spectacle incroyable des
éclairs de différentes couleurs juste au
dessus de nos têtes
en 2015 il y a eu un véritable pic
d'activité solaire il y a eu plusieurs
apparitions d'aurores boréales cette
année là à saint pétersbourg j'ai pensé
que ce serait super de réunir quelques
amis partageant la même envie d'aller à
la chasse
et vous janvier l'instinct esker une
aurore boréale vous a plus marqué que
les autres
beaucoup elles sont toutes très
différentes
j'ai été très marqué par la première
déjà je commençais à faire mon travail
de recherche sur les auront sans en
avoir encore vu et à résoudre des
équations un petit peu compliqué et la
première que j'ai vu m'a fait peur
c'était ma première action et après j'ai
éclaté de rire évidemment ça faisait
quand même un angle de je travaillais
dessus il y en a eu d'autres je me suis
retrouvé une fois très près du pôle nord
qu à l'extérieur et -30 -40 degrés et le
ciel est devenu tout rouge et six heures
en rouge c'est quand même très très rare
de les voir et là j'étais vraiment très
très content c'était d'un vin rouge
pourpre cardinal très intense c'était
vraiment extrêmement bout d'autres
d'autres horreurs il ya eu des erreurs
qui ressemble à des grands pylônes qui
traversent le ciel traite est très
stable donc à plateforme d'horreur mais
ces trois là vont certainement beaucoup
beaucoup impressionné alors vous voulez
observé à des fins scientifiques
comment vous est venu cet intérêt pour
ces phénomènes
je voulais absolument faire de
l'astrophysique donc j'ai suivi une
formation d'astrophysique et puis quand
il s'est agi de choisir un sujet de
thèse
le sujet était une description
extrêmement scientifique de
l'interaction entre l'activité solaire
et et la terre ce qui m'a permis de voir
une première au rang et là je suis tombé
dedans d'une finance est clair c'est ça
que je veux faire c'est trop beau c'est
magique et puis quand on est face à une
oran on est en connexion directe
physique 1 je parle pas de quelque chose
d'ésotérique avec le cosmos on sait que
ce sont des particules qui sont partis
depuis quelques heures à quelques jours
du soleil et qui ont produit
à la suite de tout ce que j'ai décrit
tout à l'heure cette lumière qui arrive
dans vos hits donc c'est une vraie
connexion physique est pour moi le fait
de comprendre la mécanique physique
rajoute à la poésie de 10 phénomène mais
alors qu'est-ce qu'on étudie quand on
l'étudié une aurore polaire
les aurores polaires sont la partie
immergée de l'iceberg c'est à dire celle
qu'on voit le plus quoi en réalité cette
activité solaire à beaucoup d'autres
impacts sur l'environnement de la terre
elle donc qu elle produit de
l'électricité dans la haute atmosphère
et cette électricité peut troubler les
télécommunications est abîmée des
satellites par exemple et quand l abîme
des satellites et pour aussi troublé
tout ce qu'ils aient positionnement
global le gps un homme le positionnement
et puis à laurianne gps il ya glonass il
ya galilée ou non il ya plusieurs
systèmes elle peut elle peut aussi
affecter la vie des cosmonautes elle
peut troubler à s'est spectaculairement
les
le transport de l'électricité au sol
aucun beaucoup d'impact mais ces impacts
concerne les plus grosses industries
mondiales c'est à dire l'électricité et
l'énergie l'aviation le spatial de
positionnement donc il ya beaucoup de
choses à faire dans cette discipline
qu'on appelle la météorologie de
l'espace est ce qu elles peuvent être
dangereuses 16 ans rabo real les aurores
elle même ne sont pas dangereuses elles
ne sont ni dangereuse mini sonore
il ya des vieux mythe comprenez que
comme elles se produisent au dessus de
80 kilomètres d'altitude c'est à dire
qu'à se produisent au dessus de la
couverture nuageuse donc pour les voir
il faut qu'il fasse une vie complètement
nul il faut vraiment aucun éclairage
urbain rien il faut papier de nuages
même la lune est embêtante donc l'ennemi
on voit le plus c'est haut rang boréale
c'est l'ennemi polaire un très très
froide où il n'ya pas de lune on voit
rien il n'y a pas de l'image et donc
c'est l'ennemi ou où les gens mouraient
de faim par exemple d'effroi par pas de
faim bien sûr de froid et puis c'est
l'élu où la neige devient tellement
froide quelle semaine ok si bien que
toutes les légendes pendant des siècles
des siècles jusqu'au xxème siècle en
fait toutes les légendes autour d oran
son maléfique les haut rang étaient
associés à des choses dramatiques et
donc il reste encore un petit peu d des
résurgences de ces légendes qui disent
oh la la c'est dangereux les oranje mais
ce ne l'est pas vous êtes donc
spécialistes de la météorologie de
l'espace donc moi j'ai appris qu'il y
avait une météo dans l'espace f que est
ce qu'il ya des saisons est ce qu'il ya
des pluies des sécheresses
oui oui c'est une bonne pomme ne l'avait
jamais dit présenté comme ça mais c'est
excellent vous avez absolument raison le
soleil est une étoile variable en temps
normal il envoie un vent solaire
relativement lent alors lent lent pour
nous ça veut dire typiquement 370 km par
seconde au niveau de la terre happy
temps en temps et l'envoi des grosses
bouffées de particules dans l'espace
alors ça peut se produire à travers
différents mécanismes éruptif qu'on
appelle des éjections de masse coronale
des éruptions solaires ça n'a pas une
grande importance la dame la dame en
montre dans votre reportage d'ailleurs
et donc quand le soleil envoie beaucoup
de l'électricité dans dans l'espace on
dit qu'il est actif il ya des cycles
d'activité
typiquement un soleil est calme ça dure
quelques années de trois ans et qui
devient de plus en plus actif c'est le
cas en ce moment et pendant pendant
trois-quatre ans devient actif au bout
de cinq ans à partir du départ 5 6 ans
il est très actif et là on a beaucoup de
chance de voir des aurores c'est ce qui
est dit dans votre reportage ce sera le
cas typiquement en 2025 et puis ensuite
ça reprend 5 6 7 ans pour revenir à un
état calme donc il ya des saisons des
sondés saison solaire
et est-ce qu'elles ont un impact sur nos
propres saison sur notre climat
c'était une question très importante les
climato sceptiques ou longtemps prétendu
que le réchauffement climatique était
due à l'activité solaire parce que au
cours d'une
32-34 décennies jusque dans les années
2000 le soleil il ya eu des cycles très
important avec de l'activité solaire
très importante
il ils ont beaucoup cité mes travaux
malheureusement pour servir leurs propos
si bien que j'ai j'ai créé avec un
moment collectif du docte vite à orléans
on a créé un groupe européen ont été au
prix de 120 chercheurs a étudié comment
l'activité solaire pourrait impacter le
climat de la terre est ce qu'on a trouvé
c'est que il ya quelques impacts locaux
puisqu'il ya des aurores boréales
forcément il ya des chose locale qui se
passe et ça peut impacter localement le
climat mais ça ne te pas l'impact est
globalement comme ce qu'on est en train
de constater et surtout pas dans la
proportion qu'on est en train de
constater donc si ça a un impact c'est
un impact qui est négligeable par
rapport au réchauffement climatique dû à
l'activité humaine alors justement le
climat c'est l'une des grandes
préoccupations de notre époque le 9 août
dernier
le giec c'est donc le groupe d'experts
intergouvernemental sur l'évolution du
climat a publié son dernier rapport dans
ce document il alerte sur les
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
vous partagez cette inquiètude
je partage totalement ses inquiétudes
quant on a terminé nos travaux
sur ce projet européen dont je vous
parle on a évidemment rendu compte au
giec et on s'est rendu compte que
c'était une question que le j acceptais
poser lui-même on a eu beaucoup de
discussions très fructueuses et il est
clair que l'activité solaire n'est pas à
l'origine du réchauffement climatique
mais qui a beaucoup beaucoup de choses
dans l'activité humaine qui explique
très facilement le réchauffement
climatique donc oui je suis en pleine
convergence avec le gia qui a aucun
doute là dessus
jean lynch ten nous allons marquer une
petite pause nous nous retrouvons dans
quelques minutes pour continuer à
débriefer ce documentaire sur les
chasseurs de rohr a tout de suite
les chasseurs d'aurores boréales on
continue à en parler dans le débrief du
dock avec jean l'île hoste un astronome
et planétologues à grenoble merci d'être
avec nous
partir à la recherche des aurores
boréales c'est en partie votre métier et
c'est parfois une véritable expédition
écouter ce que nous raconte natalia que
nous suivons dans ses documentaires
la route est impraticable
personnes à déneiger les routes
glacées neige sur la route mais il faut
bouger
[Musique]
mes amis et ma famille il me disait mais
tu es folle où tu vas les routes sont
mauvaises la forêt dangereuse il ya des
cerfs des ours bruns soit 6000 vie
après quelques années se sont habitués
et ne s'inquiète plus
je la neige jusqu'à la taille
[Musique]
nous devons partir tôt demain matin et
voilà que tous ces gens courent sur la
plage la moitié d'entre eux ne sont même
pas photographe
la communauté aurora hunters n'a pas
pour objectif de prendre de belles
photos
c'est surtout pour se faire plaisir et
voir si on a de la chance
[Musique]
alors pour voir des aurores boréales
est-ce qu'il faut toujours braver des
conditions extrêmes
oui
presque c'est à dire que pour les voir
il faut qu'il fasse nuit et il faut
s'approcher du pôle magnétique la dent
dans ce reportage les gens vont au près
du lac lagoda le bloc la godaille les à
61 4 degrés de latitude nord mais c'est
la latitude par rapport aux pôles
géographiques
imaginez qu'on peut parfaitement faire
la même chose inclus pôles magnétiques
et c'est seulement à 57 degrés 58 degrés
de latitude nord dans ce cas c'est mieux
si on monte encore plus haut si on monte
à 66 1 de glee voyait sur ces images les
aurores sont très bas sur l'horizon si
c'est aller un peu plus au nord ils
auront les oranje juste au dessus de
leurs têtes ils ont été encore plus
beaucoup voilà donc il faut aller près
du pôle nord près du pôle nord
magnétique sion va exactement pôle nord
on en a plus d oran à cause de ce que je
racontais tout à l'heure du fait que les
particules se déposent sur un cône pour
aller vers le pôle donc voilà on n'y
vont pas vous mieux ne pas aller
exactement pôle nord et puis il faut
qu'il fasse nuit donc on est dans la
nuit polaire un bien sûr si on y va à
partir de mars avril déjà il fait trop
chaud on peut plus les voir le mieux
c'est d'y aller quand ya pas de lune sur
des reportages il ya de la lune et ça ça
écrase un peu les couleurs d europe donc
c'est effectivement des conditions
difficiles il faut se couvrir à la
température moi je vais souvent à la
peau ni la température descend -20 -30
je vais aussi un arc tic de classe et
très aux normes pour d'autres raisons
scientifiques j'ai besoin d'y aller et
là la température descend à -30
facilement mais on sait s'ouvrir c'est
pas très grave on met un cache nez on se
protège les oreilles qui peuvent casser
ainsi fait très froid les oreilles
casseneuil chaussée protéger le nez
c'est pareil peut casser on se protège
le nez aux mets des doudounes on met des
pantalons on empile les pantalons et
puis on a des grosses chaussures qui
voit là tout va bien ce documentaire est
tournée en russie est ce que c'est une
région de prédilection pour voir des
aurores boréales
alors il ya toute cette zone doc quand
je parlais de ce grand compte sur lequel
se déposent les vents solaires ça fait
si on regarde du dessus un cercle autour
du pôle nord magnétique on l'appelle
l'ovale auroral il y en a un au nord et
au sud et il faut aller dans cette
aubaine morales est au ballon ovale
c'est planétaire un couvreur l'alaska y
recouvre tout une grande partie de la
sibérie tout nord de la russie et puis
en europe et bah c'est toute la
scandinavie la scandinavie enfin la
laponie en fait il faut pas plus
d'ailleurs ça la laponie frappé le pays
samedi donc c'est tout le pays ça nous
donc c'est vraiment planète tous les
pays qui ont des des terres en hautes
latitudes sont concernés vous travaillez
à l'institut de planétologie et
d'astrophysique de grenoble
vous êtes donc chasseur d'aurores
boréales mais est-ce que vous en chasser
en france
ça c'est super intéressant les mêmes
phénomènes qui crée de la lumière dans
les aurores boréales existe aussi à
toutes les latitudes y compris en france
et 6 est même allé les voir en afrique
mais les
l'intensité lumineuse est tellement
faible tellement aînés que c'est
impossible de les voir avec les yeux si
un petit juste impossible on allonge
avant qu'un instrument si vous
travaillez ainsi pas grand chose tu as
inventé un instrument qui me permet non
seulement de les voir et qui me permet
de voir comment vivre cette lumière ça
tu es assez amusant parce que ça permet
comme comme une nouvelle fenêtre sur
notre environnement spatial comme si on
ouvrait à rideau sur une scène il ya
toute la scène a exploré et on voit
toutes ses couleurs des aurores boréales
à toutes les latitudes donc j'étais au
sénégal avant les confinements et puis
pendant les confinements j'ai fait des
observations dans les alpes où j'ai vu
toutes ses couleurs en signe
mais être chasseur d'aurores boréales ce
n'est pas réservé qu'aux professionnels
comme vous c'est une activité qui réunit
beaucoup d'amateurs des passionnés qui
sont parfois même très équipés regardez
les aurores boréales que nous voyons à
ce moment sont très faibles c'est dû à
la faible activité solaire
les erreurs les plus belles apparaîtront
vers 2025
on pourra les voir dans le ciel de saint
pétersbourg elles seront très intense et
de couleurs très variées
alors on s'en doute un spécialiste comme
vous donc ce n'est pas si simple de
repérer des aurores boréales mais on a
l'impression dans cet extrait qu'il y a
quand même des signes annonciateurs est
ce qu'il est ce qu'il ya des saisons
privilégié o'shea
alors donc c'est mieux si le soleil est
actif
on commence à savoir prévenir l'activité
solaire et à savoir dire si cette
activité va avoir un impact sur la terre
mis à plusieurs centres de prévision il
y en a évidemment en europe
le centre de prévision le plus important
en europe se trouve en belgique
et pour pour les veaux téléspectateurs
ça s'appelle
stc qui veut dire solar terrestrial
center of excellence et on peut
s'inscrire c'est gratuit et avoir des
bulletins d'alert qui veut dire s'il ya
de l'activité solaire et si on peut
avoir des chances devant des oranje il
existe des centres identique dans
beaucoup de pays maintenant il y en a en
australie pour tous qui hémisphère sud
évidemment les états unis eau le leur
l'angleterre vient la grande bretagne la
grande bretagne vient de mettre en place
le sien et puis on a aussi en russie
bien sûr et c'est celui-là que regarde
la dame sûr si on en reportage que vous
avez diffusé
alors il ya une dizaine d'années vous
avez créé trois récompenses des
médailles annuel de la météo de l'espace
qui sont remises à des scientifiques
elles sont décernés par les académies
des sciences de belgique norvège et
russie
quel est le but
il ya plusieurs buts le premier est que
peu à peu on a créé cette discipline
dans les années 90 j'étais tout jeune
chercheur et cette discipline s'appelle
la météorologie de l'espace
on est devenus très mûrs en météorologie
de l'espace et j'ai pensé que pour
affirmer notre maturité créer un jeu de
médailles de récompenses internationales
c'était quelque chose d'important ça
nous permettait de dire voyez il y en a
parmi nous qui sont vraiment
exceptionnelles et qui méritent la
reconnaissance du monde la deuxième ma
deuxième démarche était que je suis
désolé j'espère que l'ue peut paraître
trop sérieux avance téléspectateurs mais
il me semble que 1 des rôle principal de
la science et de servir la paix est là
la coopération internationale il faut
qu'on échange de savoirs et on doit être
on dirait des exemples sinon on se
rappelle de stephen faille dès avant la
seconde guerre mondiale qui le disaient
qu'ils allaient partout pour dire
servons la paix on aidé des
intellectuels je crois qu'il faut le
faire c'est pourquoi j'ai décidé de
créer trois médailles une pour des
jeunes chercheurs une pour un chercheur
qui a fait des choses exceptionnelles en
sciences et une pour quelqu'un qui a
fait des choses exceptionnelles pour
faire connaître la météorologie qui ce
passe et j'ai décidé qu'il fallait avoir
des noms de grands chercheurs
internationaux pour ses trois médailles
j'en voulais un dans l'union européenne
en scandinavie et un dans les pays de
l'est et c'était la russie et la
démarche était vraiment celle là de dire
au delà de tous nos différents
géopolitique nous scientifiques sommes
capables d'échanger et de parler les uns
avec les autres voilà j'espère que
c'était pas trop ces annuel néanmoins
alors ma démarche était complètement
acceptés aux académies des sciences et
la russie a dit 'nous on a chip skik un
grand monsieur que maintenant j'aime
beaucoup et on aimerait que ce soit
qu'ils ce qui donne le nom à cette
médaille est évidemment avec mon comité
international j'ai accepté et alors
qu'ils aient ce qui est un gage absolu
mans incroyable ce qu'il a ce qu'il a
pensé dans les années au tout début du
20e siècle c'est que l'activité solaire
était à l'origine
de beaucoup de choses dans le climat est
que ces impacts est les récoltes alors
s'est il s'avère que c'est faux mais
c'était formidable d'hab c'est le
premier qui a eu l'idée que l'activité
solaire qu'il y avoir d impact sur notre
vie quotidienne et c'est la naissance un
terreau logique l'espace n'a d'autre à
qui vendre dans le monde qui ont des
idées similaires mais voilà lui il a eu
le premier cette idée là donc un gars un
gars incroyable un grand précurseur qui
a été en plus un poète un peut être
quelqu'un bien qu est cette médaille je
suis inscrit à qui elle est qu'elle un
type de scientifiques et elle est remise
alors tous les ans on a on lance un
appel mondial et puis il ya des réponses
donc là la date limite pour cette année
c'est mi septembre et puis ensuite j'ai
un comité international qui travaille
qui épluche absolument tous les tous les
dossiers qui sont envoyées on a eu on a
eu en fait des médailles qui ont été
données à des russes et des américains
évidemment à des européens à deux
chinois un japonais en fait c'est
vraiment totalement international comme
ce sont les premières médailles de la
discipline ils sont devenus prestigieuse
l'an dernier on a eu deux ministres de
la recherche et
le directeur adjoint de la nasa qui ont
anticipé à la remise des médailles aux
médaillés
vous nous le disait donc jean lil'
einstein pas de frontières pour la
recherche comme pour les aurores
boréales merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
astronomes et planétologues à grenoble
et que vous êtes vous même chasseur
d'aurores boréales merci d'avoir
débriefer ce documentaire avec nous
merci pour votre accueil merci mille
fois en juin
c'est la fin du débrief du dock une
émission à retrouver sur notre site
internet arte france ptv très bonne
journée à tous merci
m